I never saw I'll get me over also I'm
getting Hana on ice driveway into a
mountain stand on top of this big tank
of water her prisoner see you at war for
more than 50 years Japan has been at the
forefront of big physics creating
experiments of such size and ambition
that they need to be seen to be believed
my name is Davide Caston Dickey and I am
one of nature's physics reporters in
this series I will be traveling to Japan
to visit three of its flagship
experiments delving inside Japan's big
physics
[Music]
this is kameoka a tiny village nestled
in the shadow of Mount econo in Gifu
Prefecture Japan it is an unassuming
village but there is more than meets the
eye it is home to the control center of
the Kamioka observatory and the world's
largest neutrino detector
super-kamiokande located under the
neighboring mountain is one of the
elementary particles
sometimes weak poles as Newton also goes
to particles that means nutrional travel
in light speed everywhere and neutrino
paths through everything so it's really
difficult particles to detect that's why
new Tonio has many mysteries and that is
where super-kamiokande comes in the
machine under the mountain designed to
detect the ghost particle
we're standing here at the entrance of
the tunnel that leads to the
super-kamiokande detector it's about
2,000 meters down this tunnel to the
left but neutrinos aren't the only
particles racing through the atmosphere
super-k is built under a mountain to
make sure that neutrinos aren't drowned
out by other particles only neutrinos
can get through that much rock but even
after filtering out the noise scientists
still cut the techno tree nose until
they interact with something new tunnel
basically passed through everything
however with very very small probability
it interact with the mapa so to increase
the tiny odds they built a water tank 10
stories high filled with 50,000 tons of
pure water and the water in the tank is
what the neutrinos will occasionally
smash into if Newton or interact with
this water there it was flashlight and
this flashlight can be observed by the
what offences so that's how the photo
sensors are called photomultiplier tubes
or PMT's and they look somewhat like
giant light bulbs they are so sensitive
they could spot a candle on the surface
of the Moon so this is one of the
photomultiplier tubes it's a high vacuum
inside and whenever there is a neutrino
event happening in the water the light
that is produced by the event hits maybe
a few dozen or a few hundreds of these
photomultiplier tubes when I visited
super-kamiokande spotter tank had been
emptied for the first time in 12 years
for maintenance
this is the super-k time so later you
can see clearly not expect to see right
away I was lucky enough to have Massa
Yuki Nakata invite me to take a look
inside but first we had to suit up so
I'm putting on this vest to reduce the
amount of contamination that we can
leave inside the plan was to llores into
the tank on a tiny Khandala the first
glimpse down the hatch feels like
looking through a portal into another
universe or through the door of dr. who
started as the gondola is lowered down
one feels the stare of 11,000 giant
orange eyes the PMT's aren't really
orange they are reflecting the color of
the sodium lamps inside used to prevent
damage to the sensors it's really weird
to be in there the PMT's form a regular
geometric pattern that confuses one
sense of proportions and distances as if
seen from the inside the tank could be
even bigger than it already is
from the bottom of the tank I could see
the space above us as well as the work
being carried out beneath it is hard to
overestimate the engineering feat that
creating this experiment has been and it
is paying off so Parker detector hosted
by Japan discovered Newton oscillations
neutrino oscillations showed that
neutrinos must have some tiny but
nonzero mass
and that was a huge surprise so much so
that the discovery won a Nobel Prize the
second Nobel to come out of this
formidable Observatory this nutrition is
really breakthrough beyond the standard
model and we believe there's more higher
theory beyond this standard model and
then this discovery of newton
oscillation provide some window to see
the new physics next the researchers at
Super K are setting their sights on
trying to spot the decay of protons
which has never been seen before
they will also be adding a metal called
gadolinium to the water to make Super K
more sensitive to stray neutrinos from
ancient supernovas and they are about to
start building an even bigger experiment
hyper kamiokande a detector that will be
five times larger than super-kamiokande
we aim to discover proton decay that's
not yet discovered in the pocket another
wall is we aim to discover the
difference between utano and anti
neutrino so Hapuku has many gaps its
goals for decades scientists here at
kamyaka have been pushing the boundaries
on neutrino research and the discoveries
they are making are changing our
understanding of the universe in the
next episode
we're heading back under mount Kenna but
to see a very different experiment
kaga Japan's answer to like it's very
own gravitational wave detector
[Music]